les urgences les urgences de nos
hôpitaux et ma belle macro et la
ministre de la santé brigitte
bourguignon se rendent à l'hôpital de
cherbourg demain la crise est majeur 120
services d'urgence prévoit des
fermetures partielles cet été fabriqué
au chu de bordeaux les urgences sont en
alerte rouge le service manque de
personnel pour accueillir tout le monde
alors ces agents de la sécurité civile
sont chargés de faire le tri on peut
plus accepter en permanence 7 jours sur
7 tous les patients qui viennent aux
urgences on n'en a plus les moyens donc
il faut sélectionner
les patients qui en ont vraiment besoin
c'est ce qu'on fait en ce moment même
désarroi à l'hôpital de chinon en indre
et loire par manque de soignants les
urgences et la maternité sont fermés
depuis bientôt deux semaines sans date
de réouverture connu aujourd'hui on n'en
peut plus tout se casse la gueule et
voilà on assiste on assiste à la fin de
l'hôpital avec un droit au moins 120
services d'urgence serait actuellement
contraints de limiter leurs activités en
cause l'accès insuffisant à la médecine
de ville dans certains territoires mais
surtout le manque de lits dans les
autres services qui se décharge sur les
urgences créant un effet entonnoir avant
la pandémie notre système et les terres
ronger à l'océan le dénonçait et tout ce
qui a été fait depuis n'a absolument pas
arrangé la situation en tout cas au
niveau d enfance puisque on a absolument
pas eu un recul sur la politique de
fermetures de lits encore dix sept mille
lits fermés sous le quinquennat mâcon
donc on voit bien que la volonté de
fermer des lits et de supprimer du
personnel continue malgré deux ans de
pandémie
malgré tous les scandales qui a pu la
voir au niveau de la santé chez les
urgences devienne un service qui va être
que la mettre en danger les patients on
a déjà eu des morts notamment à
strasbourg ou à orléans des conditions
de travail dégradées comme ici à
bordeaux où des patients attendent leur
prise en charge entassés dans un couloir
de quoi entraîner une hausse
spectaculaire des arrêts maladie et
malgré la majoration des heures
supplémentaires ou le recours à
l'intérim le recrutement des soignants
est en panne même dans les hôpitaux
franciliens on en a 1000 de moins qu'il
ya un an à la même époque on avait prévu
de créer 400 postes supplémentaires on
n'a pas pu les créer donc il nous manque
1400 d'infirmières par rapport à ce
qu'on aimerait avoir diona qui ont
changé de métier il y en a qui sont
partis dans le privé il y en a qui sont
partis en province il y en a qui sont
pas venus travailler après la
diplomation de l'été dernier les
soignants redoutent un été chaotique aux
urgences leurs syndicats appellent à la
mobilisation le 7 juin
les urgences sont en train de craquer on
en débat tout de suite avec
mes invités zena brillait bonjour
bienvenue vous êtes délégué général de
la fédération hospitalière de france
wilfrid s'amuse bonjour un jour cette
médecin délégué de l'association des
médecins urgentistes de france fait
bizarre bonjour bonsoir économie
spécialisé questions de santé vous
publiez l'autonomie solidaire en santé
c'est aux éditions michalon j'accueille
également avec nous en duplex vincent
couronne le fondateur et directeur de la
publication des surligneurs médias de
vérification
de la légalité on va dire de l'aspect
légal des discours politiques bonsoir
vincent merci d'être là et matthieu
croissandeau éditorialiste politique qui
restait à mes côtés je vous propose
cette carte de pour pour commencer pour
prendre tout de suite conscience de la
détresse de l'eau services d'urgence 120
qui prévoit 120 service qui prévoit des
fermetures partielles ou alors une
régulation de l'accès aux services ou
alors des délestages d'ici à cet été et
labriet ça représente quoi 20% de nos
hôpitaux qui sont d'ores et déjà touchés
qui disent on n'y arrivera pas cet été
en fait nous nous avons 80% de nos
établissements publics de santé qui
connaissent des difficultés
alors soit sur des services ciblés comme
par exemple les urgences ou bien d'ordre
général plusieurs services touchés est
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
on demande à l'hôpital de pallier les
manques de notre système de santé donc
chaque année en période pré estivale
on rencontre des difficultés sauf que là
c'est une crise aiguë que nous vivons
après deux ans de pandémie qui a
entraîné de l'usure de la fatigue des
professionnels et par conséquent de
l'absentéisme donc effectivement la
situation est plus grave que d'habitude
bien sûr qu'on continue à soigner des
patients et accueillir les patients et
pour pouvoir continuer à le faire et
passer l'été c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut absolument qu'on mette
en place un certain nombre de mesures
d'ores et déjà oui alors on en parlera
des mesures d'urgence et puis évidemment
de ce qu'il faut faire voir un peu plus
loin à moyen et long terme où il fait sa
vitesse que vous avez déjà connu une
situation aussi critique
on dit et je pense d'ailleurs qu'on n'a
pas encore touché le fond de la piscine
oui on a on a connu alors je pensais que
naïvement le coc vidal être la der des
der mais malheureusement c'est comme en
14 il y en a une après c'est vrai que
c'est d'ailleurs même un facteur de
cette utilisation des problèmes parce
que les praticiens en poste avait un
espoir énorme avec risque aux ide ont
nourri enfin le l'espoir de voir leur
demande de soigner avec plus de moyens
et donc plus de compassion vis-à-vis des
patients on avait cet espoir de le voir
réaliser en fait non et donc il ya eu un
seigneur de la santé lauriac monsieur v
ans pour se réjouir du ségur de la santé
c'est à dire que moi je suis et je vais
pas faire de la politique mais mais
malheureusement le problème est là c'est
à dire qu'on peut pas annoncer avoir
vaincu le coc vidé et être satisfait de
son statut constat politique et de voir
que l'hôpital public et et comme on le
décrit aujourd'hui quoi s'est jouée la
satisfaction gr il faut qu'il m'explique
ce que ce que pour lui le mot rentrer
dans l'histoire signifie parce que là
sincèrement et ça provoque à chaque fois
beaucoup de colère de voir cette espèce
de déni je vais rebondir sur sur le
thème d'un côté quoi c'est à dire que le
tout à l'heure on parlait de du déni
d'une ministre de l'intérieur là on a un
déni complet de la santé du dauphin des
responsables de la santé de monsieur de
verront alors je sais pas ce que madame
bourguignon va nous apporter mais
sincèrement je crois que c'est tant
qu'on n'aura pas nommé les vrais
problèmes et qu'on n'aura pas dit oui
effectivement il y a un problème de
financement de l'hôpital public il y a
un problème de réarmer le désir des
praticiens hospitaliers qui ont été
rasées par deux années de d'épidémie de
covin tant qu'on n'aura pas à poser ses
problèmes sur la table on n'arrivera à
rien et d'ailleurs les patients dont on
souffre et comptons continuer d'en
souffrir fallait bizarre cette crise
elle est structurelle c'est peut-être ça
la première chose qu'il faut dire le
plus je crois que c'est là c'est en
effet cette ce diagnostic qu'il faut
faire partager c'est le sociologue alain
touraine qui disait qu avant tout phase
de décomposition
en tout cas se re construction et de
recomposition des modèles d'être une
phase de décomposition de délitement on
est dans cette phase de délitement
depuis une dizaine d'années avec
évidemment pour certains services pour
certains lieux de soins qui sont des d
effet loupe l'effet miroir de cette
dégradation du système et ils service
des urgences je prends juste un chiffre
un quart des passages aux urgences sont
un quart des patients qui vont aux
urgences représentent les deux tiers des
passages aux urgences pour quoi parce
que ce sont les personnes âgées qui sont
polis medic et dont un peu et qui ont
plusieurs pathologies qui sont plus
apolitiques et qui sont fragiles et
plutôt que d'être prises en charge soit
à leur domicile soit dans l'ambulatoire
soit dans l'est dans le médico social
dans les ehpad et ben finissent aux
urgences bon voilà donc c'est bien le
délitement de la ville du médico social
qui fait que les bons donc ça au moins
faudrait le partage et c'est l'entonnoir
problème de samut est très important
c'est que et c'est pas que le politique
pourquoi est ce que le politique ne
prend pas conscience qu'il faut vraiment
refonder le système même si l ennemi
qu'il en aurait pas le lez lille idée de
comment faire c'est parce que vous avez
une espèce de
d'une autre administration une partie de
l'administration il suffit on a écouté
une partie là qui elle-même et 7
défendre un système qui est un système
dépassé d'accord dont vous prenez des
directeurs des ars des directeurs de de
l'ap-hp d' ap hm donc il ya et c'est eux
qui parlent aux politiques c'est eux qui
sont écoutés par le politique donc je
crois que le politique quelque part doit
être un petit peu en contact direct avec
situ des soignants mais la population en
général pour avoir passé quelques temps
aux urgences pour un accident il ya
trois mois vous vous rendez compte que
on est arrivé à un état de dégradation
qui est inacceptable pour un pays comme
la france quand vous restez six à sept
heures deux sur des brancards en train
de gémir de douleur et qu'on vous dit
faut attendre votre tour vous comprenez
qu'il ya un problème oui d'accord et
j'ai lu si on répond qu'il ya des gens
qui sont arrivés à 14 heures qui sont
toujours pas pris en charge donc nous
avons voilà donc et ça c'est
inacceptable pour les patients mais pour
les soignons aussi donc on peut dire il
faut augmenter les soignants il vous
reviendra sur le ségur qui et quand on
met 10 milliards sur la table et qu'on
obtient quelque chose qui fait fuir les
ressources humaines faut quand même
accepté qu'on a probablement rater des
choses en a raté trois choses il faut y
font n'a oublié la pénibilité on a
oublié les contractuels c'est 40 % juste
de la masse salariale et on a oublié la
différenciation des compétences on a dit
tout le monde pareil non on y reviendra
peut-être sur dresse sur ce qui ce qui
va se passer cet été avec une question
très basique de deux citoyens est ce que
les urgences seront assurées
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
tous ces hôpitaux qui sont là qui nous
disent on n'y arrivera pas où on y
arrive déjà pas et justement pour qu'on
puisse les assurés ces urgences il faut
d'ores et déjà que dans chaque
territoire sous la houlette des agences
régionales de santé elles mettent en
place des plans de continuité de soins
de savoir les filières qu'on doit
prioriser cons et qu'on garantisse
l'accès en journée et la nuit parce
qu'il ya un point qu'on n'a pas évoqué
c'est que si l'hôpital et aussi dans
cette situation c'est que il y à des
déserts médicaux qu'on le veuille ou non
est par ailleurs il y a des tout le
monde n'est pas présent pour assurer le
premier recours et le problème numéro un
il est là donc les patients quand ils
ont pas accès à leur médecin traitant
ils essayent ils vont aux urgences de
l'hôpital donc très simplement on a su
pendant la crise pour mettre en place
des centres de vaccination mobiliser
tout le monde là il faudrait d'ores et
déjà mobilisé tout le monde tous les
acteurs de santé
les cliniques les hôpitaux les libéraux
avec les élus pour définir quelles
priorités quelles filières sont
prioritaires de soi comment on
s'organise quelle structure est ouverte
quels cabinets sont ouverts pour qu'on
puisse garantir au moins un plan de
continuité des soins
se retrouvent pas aux urgences
et avoir accès à de la téléconsultation
on peut aussi être parce que le problème
c'est les urgences et les soins non
programmés
je voudrais donner la parole une
première fois vincent couronne pour
avoir un regard juridique parce que il
ya une obligation légale vincent
d'accueillir les personnes en détresse
oui on déjà il ya une obligation de
continuité du service public de la santé
qui est une obligation qui a été
renforcée par une loi la loi touraine en
2016 notamment et qui fait que les
agences régionales de santé doivent
faire en sorte d'organiser l'accueil des
soins de telle sorte que et bien on
puisse être soignée si on est accueillis
aux urgences il n'est pas normal et puis
là l'hôpital engagerait sa
responsabilité s'il a cueilli une
personne qui est décédée par faute de
personnel suffisant dans ses couloirs
mais il ya autre chose c'est que réguler
du coup l'entrée l'entrée dans des dans
les urgences comme on l'a vu par exemple
à bordeaux où la nuit les adultes
doivent appeler le 15 pour savoir où ils
sont redirigés si les urgences ou pas si
une personne se présente à l'entrée des
urgences devant un hôpital et qu'elle
est souffrante et bien là il ya une
obligation effectivement de porter
secours c'est une obligation qui fait
partie de la déontologie des médecins ou
des infirmiers de venir en aide à des
blessés en péril et ont plus de ça il ya
aussi le code pénal tout simplement
qu'ils qui créent qui a créé un délit de
non assistance à personne en péril et
qui est passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende si jamais vous ne portez pas
secours à une personne qui est en péril
donc si vous arrivez souffrent au seuil
d urgence un médecin ou un infirmier ne
pourra pas vous laisser dehors il ne
peut pas vous laisser dehors de toute
façon merci pour ce cette présentation
vincent couronne où il fait de sa vie de
vous êtes membre de la commission
d'indemnisation des accidents médicaux
en ile de france et si on a de plus en
plus ce cas plus en plus de passer ce qu
est la suite logique de ce qu'on décrit
de serment ce qui me fait réagir
effectivement parce que malheureusement
on est au coeur du sujet le la
conséquence de tout ça c'est
qualitativement l'acte de sens quand
vous avez vu quand vous voyez depuis des
années le temps consacré aux soins que
ce soit par les paramédicaux par les
médecins et se réduit comme peau de
chagrin du fait d'un effet démographique
épouvantable pas forcément la qualité
n'est plus au rendez vous et donc vous
avez une augmentation de dd plainte
alors c'est vrai que la loi kouchner
avant la pénalisation à permet de
d'essayer de trouver une conciliation
avec les patients qui se pose les bonnes
questions en sachant qu'ils ont attendu
le 10 heures et qu'ils ont une douleur
thoracique qui n'a été prise en compte
alors que vous savez quand vous êtes
susceptible de faire un infarctus et le
temps c'est du myocarde vous avez
effectivement légitimement une
augmentation des plaintes et une
augmentation des demandes
d'indemnisations pour des aléas qui
peuvent se trouver être finalement des
fautes faute de moyens mais vous vous
avez des chiffres là dessus c'est
d'abriès et vous confirmer que de plus
en plus de procédures qui seraient
parfois l'amiable d'ailleurs monté par
contre ce qu'on peut dire réellement
c'est qu'on a un vrai enjeu de santé
publique nous savons qu en 2020 et 2021
du fait de la crise un certain de prise
en charge n'ont pas pu être assuré qu'il
s'agisse en matière de diagnostic de
cancer qu'il s'agit selon lui en matière
de suivi de maladie et inévitablement il
va falloir rattraper tout cela donc quoi
qu'il en soit sur la prise en charge
globale des patients il y a un
retentissement et ça va bien au delà
bien au-delà de ce que vous vous évoquez
bizarre vous l'avez évoqué twitter je
rappelle vous êtes économiste de la
santé et les dysfonctionnements que vous
dénoncez depuis des années vous les avez
vécu de l'intérieur puisque vous vous
êtes retrouvé c'était en février dernier
renversé par une voiture à paris
gravement blessé vous l'avait raconté
dans un article du point dont je me
permets de
rappelez moi aussi vous vous passez
combien de temps aux urgences et puis
qu'est ce qui ressort on parle parfois
de perte de chance mais ce qu'il ya des
moments où vous dit peut-être que je
fais quelque chose de grave et on est en
train de passer à côté oui enfin vous
rendez compte quand vous êtes patient
qui vaut mieux avant un accident être en
bonne santé pour espérer passer cette
épreuve là d'un accident sur la chose
parce que quand vous n'êtes quand vous
voyez des personnes âgées qui ont tel ou
tel problème ou un accident aux vous
rendez compte qu'elles ne peuvent pas
passer cette épreuve là au delà de
l'accident que vous avez eu sans
séquelles majeures et d'ailleurs j'ai pu
voir pendant cette nuit aux urgences que
le discours un peu de tout le monde
c'est dire plus jamais ça c'est à dire
et c'est là où vous avez et quand vous
le voyez vous parlez à du personnel des
kinés vous avez les personnes âgées qui
ne veulent plus aller dans ces urgences
telles tellement c'est une épreuve de
rester sur des brancards pendant des
heures à gémir bon donc on en est là et
on en est là dans un des grands chu
parisien il fut un temps où il était bon
de dire il vaut mieux avoir un accident
à paris qu'ailleurs en province parce
qu'on n'est plus sûr de bon ça c'est
fini ce temps là voyez donc ça c'est une
réalité qu'on voit et moi je suis
convaincu que de toute façon je sais pas
si on est au fond de la piscine mais que
cette cette situation la va vite devenir
intolérable parce qu'il va y avoir des
pertes de chance mais les fermetures des
sans voix là c'est là où enfin moi c'est
ma conviction c'est que je pense que
c'est pas un problème financier c'est
pas un problème de rémunération
même si les rémunérations sont loin
d'être là c'est un problème de général
de conditions de travail de
reconnaissance du travail de deux sens
mais aussi de son sang se publie ces
deux sens à ce travail mais à quoi et à
quoi sert l'hôpital public aujourd'hui
d'accord bon on sait qu'il faut
décloisonner tous ces secteurs là on
sait qui est là attention à ne pas
penser que l'herbe est plus verte
ailleurs et que si on resserre un peu la
vis ailleurs ça va améliorer le sort de
l'hôpital c'est ce qu'on a cru avec la
loi touraine où on s'est dit tiens le
service public si on excluait le plus le
privé du service public ça ira mieux
pour le service public avec les
résultats qu'on connaît je vous prends
juste c'est monsieur mon coin n'a parlé
de service public c'est là le coeur du
gène d'accord a service public c'est
égalité d'accès c'est une continuité
d'accès est ce que rappelle la
mutabilité ces lois de rôle en 1930 bon
et bien on a considéré et ajuste le
titre que ce service public qui devait
être délivrés à l'hôpital en 20e siècle
parce que c'était les pathologies aiguës
parce que c'était à l'hôpital public on
allait construire l'excellence la
recherche le soin bon mais aujourd'hui
ce service public qui doit être inclure
l'ensemble des acteurs passés avec speak
territorial de santé qu'on soit acteur
privé ou acteurs publics on doit
délivrer un service public parce que
cette continuité des soins cet accès
pour tous aux soins et à la prévention
en particulier parce qu'on a la mauvaise
stratégie aussi on reste sur uniquement
du curatif alors qu'on sait que le
curatif ça va devenir le défaut et
l'excès ça doit devenir le le préventif
à la hausse et fabrique c'est là où il
faut tout reconstruire bon donc ce
service public il faut le réinventer oui
c'est pas rien c'est le coeur du système
qu'il faut faire c'est pas un problème
hôpital ville c'est un vrai de service
public avec une occasion manquée ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour dire que que le
c ur de la santé a été une occasion
manquée parce que là il y avait avec la
crise covin la possibilité peut-être de
l'autre moi je dirais pas que ça a été
une occasion manquée et ça a été
l'occasion de prendre conscience que
l'hôpital public avait été saigné
pendant deux décennies et que à la forme
termes
d'investissement et en termes de
conditions d'exercice de professionnels
et de rémunérations il fallait faire
quelque chose c'était les deux premières
urgences mais il y avait d'autres
thématiques à traiter est ce comme
d'accessoires parce que quand on vous
entend il ya une somme considérable
quand même qu'il était
il ya huit muller de revalorisation
non mais j'ai juste pour rappeler les
associateurs par les places 4000
créations de l'isi jeu mode si je ne me
trompe sable y en avait autant enfin
vous en avez énormément qui ont été
supprimés à 4000 sur 7 sur 17 minutes
puis on me dit tu sais c'est qu'un quart
de rattraper semblait en 15 ans en moins
non mais je n'ai jamais il y avait
quinze mille recrutements prévus dans le
secteur santé dans les ehpad et est-ce
que vous les avez vu qu'aux seuls ils ne
sont pas créés celi est ce que ces gens
ne sont pas recruter alors que
l'augmentation des quotas de formation
est réel pour former les professionnels
donc on va avoir les premières sorties
dans deux ans en revanche les fermetures
de lits ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est que dès lors pas ce que je
rappelle qu'on l'a 2 en écho vide avec
un taux d'absentéisme qui augmente et
des équipes fatiguées donc ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est que pour pouvoir
maintenir dans les meilleures conditions
possibles en sous-effectif on ferme des
lits ce qu'on ne faisait pas avant elle
enfermée pas systématiquement délit donc
un certain nombre de services sont
amenés juppé rien dire une décision
administrative de l'état pour faire des
économies c'est le service que ça n'est
pas en mesure essentielle voilà parce
que il n'ya pas sûr parce que vous
trouvez pas de perse alors c'est oui et
c'est une conjonction de facteurs soit
parce que y'avait déjà je rappelle qu'à
l'hôpital public il y avait des postes
vacants donc vous ajoutez mais sur ces
postes vacants par exemple pour les
praticiens hospitaliers vous avez des
contractuels qui exercent donc si vous
ajoutez on c'est pire à deux points
d'absentéisme en plus avec la crise
qu'ovide plus la fatigue des
professionnels et puis ça peut susciter
effectivement des départs même si on n'a
pas de départs massifs tout ceci
conforte le fait qu'on ferme des lits
pour assurer la continuité des soins et
donc c'est sporadiques en fonction de
certaines activités alors que vous
donnez la parole tout c'est parce que
vous vouliez réagir mais je vous propose
d'entendre la réaction d'un autre
urgentistes le chef des urgences de
l'hôpital delafontaine à saint denis
c'est mathias wargon il intervient alors
c'était sur france info il ya quelques
jours notamment sur ses difficultés de
recrutement on écoute chaque fois on
nous dit qu'est ce que vous proposez
alors toutes les parties politiques vous
disent on va embaucher des gens chez
nous les postes ils sont ouverts il ya
des primes et on en trouve personne
personne pour des histoires d'horreur
mais pas que pour ça pour des histoires
de conditions de travail c'est les
conditions de travail qui va falloir
changer l'intérêt du travail on peut pas
demander à une infirmière et une aide
soignante de faire ce qu'elle faisait il
ya 50 ans c'est à dire venir piquer ce
tir et c'est il faut que les gens ils
trouvent un intérêt au boulot
c'est-à-dire qu'on leur ouvre autre
chose que juste être aux soins et faire
la mine il faut qu'ils aient du contact
avec les patients plus communs plus que
ça existe maintenant il faut qu'ils
aient des perspectives de carrière où il
fait sa mue ne s'est pas seulement la
rémunération c'est dans un motel sortir
de ce débat c'est même d'ailleurs ce qui
est ce qui peut nous amener à soit on
refonde tout soit au fond de rien ou
avec les l'inefficacité habituel
c'est-à-dire sa part même si vous voulez
c'est un problème aussi éducationnel à
la base vous formez des docteurs en ce
moment par exemple vous allez les
docteurs qui arrivent à l'hôpital ils
ont pas d'encadrement des bébés docteur
donc comment voulez vous avoir dans 10
ou 15 ans ces fameux 9000 médecins
supplémentaires que qu'on nous promet
comment voulez vous qu'il soit efficient
si pendant leurs années de formation ils
ont été tiraillés entre leur chef de
clinique où leurs intérêts qui lui même
et avait des tâches qu'ils ne l'avaient
n'arrivait pas à faire donc c'est à cela
parce que les médecins qui sont là ont
pas le temps de
système du service public et je suis
désolé de le dire sait on l'a vu tout à
l'heure encore une fois je suis désolé
de rebondir sur votre sujet précédent
mais on l'a vu avec le ministère de
l'intérieur mais la magistrature est
dans le même état vous parler de mes
fonctions à l'oniam je travaille avec
des magistrats pour l'indemnisation mais
c'est les dossiers s'accumulent et on
est derrière la pile et s'il ya une
pénalisation je vous dis pas les
tribunaux dans quel état ils sont pour
traiter c'est donc c'est une une refonte
de du sol au plafond c'est à dire qu'il
faut impliquer effectivement
l'université parce que c'est un problème
de formation de deux sélections je
n'aime pas ce mot là c'est pareil quand
vous formez des docteurs voulait il faut
pas les sélectionnés il faut les former
c'est à dire c'est avant de dire on va
prendre les plus brillants on a passé
des années l'université a passé des
années à fos forêt pour essayer de
sélectionner les plus brillants qui
allait décrocher le prix nobel de
médecine arriver là on n'a pas plus de
prix nobel de médecine mais l'hôpital ne
fonctionne pas donc il ya un moment où
il va falloir effectivement se poser les
bonnes questions nous donner les moyens
à l'université de former les gens à des
fonctions de soins aux puces au sens le
plus large c'est à dire du docteur au
paramédical et leur donne et réarmer
leur désir de travailler ensemble et
quand je dis ensemble c'est pas
uniquement au sein de l'hôpital public
ou privé peu importe mais c'est aussi
dans la filière de soins et là c'est un
travail ambitieux si vous voulez parce
que ça demande aussi une coordination
avec le pré hospitaliers les moyens
effectivement été donné on a donné des
milliards au c ur mais comment on peut
arriver à un résultat et personne ne se
pose la question enfin j'aurais été
ministre je me franchement je me serais
posé la question je mets 10 milliards
sur la table je ne sais combien de
médecins et d'infirmiers qui s'en vont
et je me dis super j'ai réussi mon cou
blanc on a du temps à vouloir faire
alors les gens oui sur la c'est cette
notion jour donné la parole juste après
de la qualité de vie au travail des
personnels soignants je propose à
jonathan du prix est de nous de nous
rejoindre parce que vous on a choisi
avec vous de faire un focus sur le
travail qui a été réalisé ici au sénat
justement alors il ya eu beaucoup de
pistes d'amélioration évoqué et il y en
a sur cette question de la qualité de
vie au travail on est tout à fait aux
marins s'étaient même le coeur du
rapport sénatorial qui a été publiée fin
mars pour les sénateurs en fait
l'hôpital est vraiment rentré dans une
spirale négative
il fonctionne à flux tendu miné par le
manque de moyens de personnel et cette
situation et a été rendue d'autant plus
compliquée avec la crise du coc vie de
19 et face à ce constat alors les
sénateurs qu'est ce qu'ils proposent il
propose avant tout de revaloriser les
salaires mais au delà du saupoudrage ce
qu'ils appellent le saupoudrage du ségur
de la santé il réclame aussi un meilleur
encadrement des heures supplémentaires
et surtout un renforcement vous le voyez
des embauches
notamment des infirmiers des aides
soignants pour que le fonctionnement
finalement de de l'hôpital ne repose
plus uniquement je les cite sur la bonne
volonté et la morale du dévouement pour
bernard jomier président de la
commission denquête il faut surtout
créer un cercle vertueux
améliorer les conditions de travail
ensuite la qualité de soins s'améliora
d'elle-même et les personnels retrouvons
enfin du sens à leurs activités écouté
lui
faut redonner du sens à la mission de
l'hôpital il faut redonner du sens à des
personnels qui nous l'ont tous deux dits
ont le sentiment d'être mal traitant de
ne pas bien prendre en charge des
patients donc ça prend ça passe par des
mesures très concrètes ça passe par une
proposition que nous faisons qui est
très forte qui est d'améliorer les
ratios de soignants par patient ils se
sont dégradés ces dernières années et
vous savez quand une infirmière qui
devait prendre en charge du patient en
prend en charge 14 et bien n'a plus le
temps de faire correctement son travail
et puis dans leur rapport les sénateurs
pointe aussi la part prépondérante prise
par les services d'urgences de notre
système de santé on est tout à fait
c'est l'un des soucis majeurs 1 pointé
par les parlementaires les besoins en
santé de la population ont augmenté et
la médecine de ville ne les absorbent
que le moins au moins entre 2015 et 2018
la part de la population qui vit en zone
sous dotée en médecins est passé de 3,8
à 5 7% pointe le rapport résultat les
hôpitaux voient leur nombre d'actes
augmenté et les urgences sont en
première ligne pour les absorber le
nombre de passagers il ya d'ailleurs
bondi de 10,1 millions en 92 pour
atteindre maintenant 21 2 millions en
2019 c'est assez vertigineux la pression
sur les services d'urgence va rester
très forte pour plusieurs années encore
sachant que les premiers effets de la
fin du numerus clausus pour les médecins
généralistes ne se feront sentir qu'à
partir de 2030 d'où la nécessité de se
préparer dès maintenant et enfin le
rapport de la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale préconise de rééquilibrer
surtout la prise en charge des patients
entre les cabinets et l'hôpital mercy
jonathan pour pour tous ces détails
voulait intervenir ferreri bizarre alors
ça j'imagine que ça rejoint une partie
des recommandations elle est enfin oui
non parce que si vous voulez quand diouf
quand j'entends faut augmenter le et le
ratio des soignants parle pas sur ben
oui mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas
le ratio alors que monsieur vague on
disait de lui mais les postes sont un
vrai problème c'est qu'on trouve pas à
les soigner en off et s attaquer aux
causes de la perte complète
d'attractivité de sens voulu l'appeler
comme boulet de l'hôpital comme d autres
lieux de soins parce qu'encore une fois
c'est généraliser un bon quand même sur
le ségur parce qu'il faut céder
d'analysé d'abord il faut remettre quand
même dans le contexte comment le ségur
s'est fait dans une crise sanitaire
historique personne n'avait anticipé
même si on peut toujours anticiper les
crises sanitaires mais avec un des
pouvoirs publics absolument pas préparés
et un système extrêmement fragilisée et
donc je pense qu'il était nécessaire de
remettre une somme d'argent très
importante pour faire tenir l'hôpital
pendant cette crise et de ce point de
vue le ségur a réussi cet objectif en
revanche il est évident que sur le moyen
long terme le ségur et il n'a pas du
tout été pensé je pense correctement je
vous prends un exemple pourquoi est ce
que le personnel soignant ne veut plus
travailler la nuit parce qu'il n'y a
plus aucune incitation financière à
travailler la nuit
êtes vous paie vous êtes vous gagnez 1
euro 08 parent en plus si vous
travaillez la nuit alors qu'on a re est
souvent la nuit vous avez des
contractuels qui n'ont pas bénéficié
pour la plupart du ségur mais donc tout
le monde préfère travailler le jour
enfin excusez moi ça me semble être
quelque chose de pas très compliqué à
comprendre donc comme vous n'avez pas de
revaloriser ce qui est le coeur de des
soignants c'est à dire les tâches
pénibles forcément toutes ces tâches
pénibles ne trouve plus de demain de
ressources bon et bien les urgences
c'est en particulier sa juste un point
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a une crise aussi
généralisée
c'est comme dans toute institution si
vous n'avez pas les bonnes pour nom
n'est pas bonne
que je dirais même mettre en musique ce
qui se passe depuis hier on s'est dit il
faut payer et toutes les manettes il
faut qu'on rétablisse complètement le
système parce que on a un système qui
est beaucoup trop décentralisée beaucoup
trop dans les mains des acteurs et on
est trop loin on est allé beaucoup trop
loin dans ce sens là les ars ont tout
pouvoir sans contre-pouvoir les la
direction de l'ap-hp a tout pouvoir sans
contre-pouvoir on a on a un simulacre
démocratie sociale mais qui n'a rien
d'une démocratie sociale tomber ça et ça
c'est des choses que vous pouvez faire
très rapidement avec les acteurs qu'on
peut qu'on peut remettre un petit peu
d'aplomb et c'est essentiel alors je
voudrais et évoqué un autre thème qui
rejoint la question de la rémunération
ce matin sur france inter martin hirsch
directeur général de l'ap-hp il pointait
la responsabilité des intérimaires dans
cette crise il parle même de mercenaires
écouter et médecin senior le médecin un
peu cap et qui prennent des gardes quand
ils prennent garde ils sont payé 250 300
euros pour une garde du week-end alors
qu'un intérimaire qui va choisir d'être
mercenaires et à l'intérim peut être
pays
1500 euros il faut re la valoriser cela
ceux qui prennent mille cinq cents
balles pour pas moi quand je vais aux
urgences de lariboisière et comment
explique que ça peut être ça le tarif je
sais pas comment le qualifier autrement
et qui ce que je veux dire la médecine
c'est un travail d'équipé
se vendent comme cela si je pense que
c'est un oui j'ai un problème vincent
couronne je vous ai demandé en cet après
midi si vous pouviez regarder parce que
martin hirsch il dénonce mais jusqu'à
preuve du contraire le système il est
illégal dans quelles conditions les
hôpitaux peuvent faire appel à leur
faire appel pardon à ses à ses
intérimaires
bon ça va en droit il ya souvent le
principe est l'exception le principe en
droit c'est que la fonction publique
elle est assurée par des fonctionnaires
et c'est pareil pour la fonction
publique hospitalière
sauf que l'exception c'est que lorsqu'il
y à un manque de personnel lorsqu'il ya
des pénuries ou lorsqu'il n'ya pas les
personnes compétentes parmi les
fonctionnaires pour assurer une fonction
et bien on peut recruter des
contractuels mais ça doit rester
exceptionnel ou à des intérimaires le
problème et on l'a vu tout à l'heure
avec votre plateau que en fait c'est une
situation qui est en train petit à petit
de devenir une exception papa pas
forcément majoritaire mais mais qui ne
pourraient un jour le devenir il ya un
aiguillon probablement ici à comment
dire à garder en tête c'est la
constitution la constitution dans son
préambule elle prévoit ceci elle dit je
cite la nation garantit à tous notamment
à la femme ah pardon à l'enfant à la
mère et aux vieux aux vieux travailleurs
la protection de la santé ça c'est en
découlent de ça en fait un droit
constitutionnel à la protection de la
santé ça a des conséquences très très
pratique c'est à dire que dans le gard
en 2009 la justice a annulé un
regroupement de maternité tout
simplement parce que en regroupement ces
maternités enfin en enfermant certains
du coup et bien il y avait des femmes
enceintes qui était à plus de 40
kilomètres d'une maternité en cas de
complications le juge a dit c'est pas
possible donc il a fallu rouvrir des
maternités et donc la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on organise certes le
personnel que ça soit des fonctionnaires
ou des intérimaires pour pouvoir gérer
ces services-là 7 mai mais avant tout il
faut dire il faut que ces services
existent de toute façon donc il faut
bien l'organiser merci vincent je me
tourne vers vous et n'a brillé parce que
lille coûte combien ces intérimaires
et coûte trop cher très cher mais je
croyais moi j'y vois un peu le symbole
de l'absurdité
vous aviez dit le terme tout à l'heure
vous avez dit pour donner du sens aux
soignants il faut redonner du sens à
notre système de santé vous venez de
citer la constitution dans une
démocratie maintenir les gens en bonne
santé c'est le minimum qu'on puisse
faire est donc effectivement redonner du
sens à notre système de santé pour
qu'ils soient plus vertueux c'est
d'abord un arrêté de fabriquer des
malades parce que malgré tout vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure on est dans un
système curatif et les problèmes d'aval
de médicalisation de laval les problèmes
de non accès en bon en soi forcément ça
fabrique des malades et puis avoir un
système de santé qui soit plus vertueux
c'est que tous les acteurs de santé
s'attache à répondre aux priorités de
santé publique que nous allons avoir
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
formation des médecins c'est très bien
qu'on choisisse en premier lieu la
chirurgie réparatrice et et plastiques
moi je trouve ça très bien est ce que ce
sont là les priorités de santé publique
qui sont là aujourd'hui devant nous non
donc il faut vraiment redonner du sens à
tout notre système de santé pour qu'ils
soient plus vertueux et que ce qui nous
coûte améliore significativement
l'état de santé des populations et
surtout les maintiennent en bonne santé
ont fait sa mue de cette histoire
d'intérimaires est ce que je voulais
répondre à la par votre intermédiaire à
martin hirsch jeu j'aime beaucoup son
cynisme c'est à dire que la politique
qu'il a mise en place à l'assistance
publique a conduit les praticiens
hospitaliers et les paramédicaux à aller
vers l'intérim puisque l'hôpital était
incapable de les rémunérer décemment
donc voir même les shock rock dans les
derniers décrets il doit ya voir même
une ligne ou deux qui souligne que en se
mettant à temps partiel vous pouvez
aller faire des piges ailleurs mieux
rémunérés donc effectivement c'est c'est
quand même incroyable que ce monsieur
qui est directeur de l'ap-hp disent ah
ben oui mais finalement c'est l'intérim
qui nous fait du oui c'est l'intérêt
nous l'avons toujours dénoncé c'est à
dire qu'on peut pas faire cohabiter au
sein du même établissement pour le même
travail des praticiens qui sont payés
trois francs six sous et des
intérimaires qui touche la timbale et
donc ça a même eu un effet de de
détournement des praticiens et des
paramédicaux vers l'intérêt médical
puisque les gens ne sont quand même pas
absurde pour le même travail ils seront
mieux rémunéré et quant au problème
effectivement de la santé qui est un
bien commun effectivement il faut
revenir à cette valeur monsieur l'a
souligné alors c'est vrai que c'est un
peu dommage de devoir en passer par la
justice pour pouvoir essayer
de faire respecter l'égalité des soins
sous nos latitudes d'autant que les
tribunaux sont sûrement mieux à faire
que de régler ces litiges là en ce
moment a été exterminée il ya une
question je les poser dans des titres
donc il faut que je vous la pose aussi
alors là c'est vraiment du court terme
est-ce qu'il faut réintégrer les
soignants qui ont été non vaccinés
compte est suspendu selon me serres l'a
senti en à 15000 alors là oui je pense
qu'il n'y a pas quinze mille soignants
sur les 15000 soignant la propose sur
les 15000 qui ont été exclus faut savoir
quelle est la vraie proportion de soi où
ils sont pas tous des soignants voilà
ensuite ça pose quand même une question
fondamentale sur le bas l'exercice du
métier de soignant aussi ya à savoir que
un soignant un professionnel de santé un
tableau vaccinale qui est plus large que
celui tout à chacun parce que d'une part
il se doit de se protéger et de protéger
aussi les patients qu'il a entre ses
mains donc regardons de près mais je
pense que il ya d'autres questions qui
ceux qui sont derrière je crois que il
ya une logique lorsqu'on prend en charge
des patients se doit de les protéger
lorsqu'on choisit le métier de
professionnel de santé je sais ce que
c'est j'ai été je suis aussi
professionnels de santé eh bien on a des
obligations qu'on n'a pas dans d'autres
métiers est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut le réintégrer c'est une subornation
c'est en trente secondes c'est
impossible d'y répondre je pense que oui
alors dans l'urgence on a besoin de tout
le monde donc à partir du moment où le
risque de vide est un peu plus écartée
il n'est pas supprimé un cheveu panneau
on peut quand même essayer de ne pas se
priver d'une partie de la population
soignante par contre effectivement il
faut se poser les bonnes questions en
termes de santé publique c'est à dire
comment on en arrive à ce que des
soignants là aussi un problème
d'éducation énorme on devrait être les
porteurs les chantres d'une vaccination
ciblée moi je me pose la question
comment on en arrive là quoi c'est c'est
il faut toujours essayer de comprendre
les causes avant d'essayer d'être
radical en termes de traitement c'est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire ici merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat fric visage
rappelle le type de votre livre
l'autonomie solide en santé livre publié
aux éditions michalon merci encore merci
ici et en duplex d'avoir participé à
cette émission